on fait pas de la désobéissance il pour
farhadi obéissance civile ont fait
vraiment la désobéissance ils passent
plus on veut pas se faire passer un
message
[Musique]
on
on occupe ce lieu parce que on veut
alerter vraiment l'opinion publique est
une réelle urgence climatique ainsi que
le gouvernement qui pour l'instant est
d'une stratégie passive sur la question
alors qu'une réelle urgence
on n'a plus le temps de faire des
marches n'a plus le temps de les trucs
symbolique maintenant il faut agir et
vite
en fait pas ça pour le plaisir qu'on
voit ça c'est on pouvait on serait tous
chez nous en train de devant netflix a
regardé des séries mon espoir c'est que
les gens prennent conscience de ce qui
se passe et qu'on peut plus rester sans
rien faire que pour moi très
irresponsable de se dire ah bah leurs
comptes relatif c'est bon on a le temps
non parce qu'on ne l'a plus le temps
justement
[Musique]
l'état respecte qui sont de voir départ
qui à protéger les citoyens du coup on
est légitime donc pu respecter la loi
pour montrer d'urgence on a croisé
beaucoup de gens qui soutiennent depuis
ce matin qui passe et qui disent bon
courage qui leur amène des choses à
manger de choses à bois
[Musique]
j'ai parlé
le purin
c'est une façon de démontrer à la fois
le futur qu'on aimerait créer donc nous
avons là nous organisons des assemblées
citoyennes des activités culturelles
c'est aussi une façon d'interrompre un
peu le train teint de la vie quotidienne
qui met beaucoup de gens dans une
situation ils ont pas le temps de penser
aux questions existentielles qui vient
aujourd'hui la question la question
climatique et écologique
on s'approche d'un gouffre et les grands
tendent en tant que société se poser les
bonnes questions
nous ne sont pas là pour demander aux
politiques forcément des mesures à
mettre en place nous n'avons pas un
catalogue de mesures
ce que nous demandons c'est que en tant
que société on se pose les questions
donc on n'est pas là pour pointer du
doigt on n'est pas là pour dire monsieur
macron doit faire quelque chose parce
que même s'ils monsieur macron voulait
dans le système politique actuel il en
aurait peut-être pas la possibilité
parce que ces mines et par da par des
intérêts particuliers
ces mini par une notion de l'économie
prédatrice basé sur une croissance
exponentielle sur une planète qui ne
peut pas la supporter non clairement il
nous faut changer de système
le système politique et des systèmes
économiques pour pouvoir faire les
changements nécessaires
[Musique]
les manifestations dans laquelle il ya
une violence produisent un grand effet
médiatique mais la violence de certains
nous croient que la violence que ce soit
d'une façon morale ou d'une façon
stratégique ne sert pas son but est que
en faisant cela on a lié ni beaucoup de
gens et nous on se rend compte que pour
la question écologique on a besoin de se
poser des questions tant que société et
pour poser les questions en tant que
société on a besoin de tout le monde
donc on a besoin des enfants on a besoin
des grands parents on a besoin de tout
le monde et dès qu'on tombe dans la
violence on les perd nous sommes dans la
non violence
on accepte les conséquences de nos actes
moi je sais qu'ici je fais quelque chose
qui peut te considérer le pain qui peut
être illégal qui est interdite mais j'en
suis prêt à accepter les conséquences et
d'aller en garde à vue on espère juste
que la police sera aussi gentils avec
nous que nous on sera avec la police
mistral
[Musique]
ça va sauver
on
[Musique]